وبعد مرور 11 يوما على وقوع الزلزال تبدو
فرص العثور على ناجله تحت الانقاذ مستحيله
غير ان هناك قصص نجاه اشبه بالمعجزات
انبعثت من تحت الركام فبعد مرور
248 ساعه على وقوع الزلزال تمكنت فرق
لانقاذ التركيه من اخراج فتاه تبلغ من
العمر 17 عاما من تحت انقاض مبنى انهار في
اقليم كرمان مراش بجنوب وسط تركيا
[موسيقى]
وقبل قليل المشاهدين انتشرت فرق لانقاذ
التركيه امراه على قيد الحياه من تحت
الانقاض في مدينه كرمان مرعش ايضا بعد
مرور 258 ساعه على الزمساء
[تصفيق]
عمليا تبدو حظوظ العثور على احياء تحت
الانقاض ضعيفه للغايه بعد اليوم السابع من
وقوع اي زلزال لكن هناك قصصا لناجينا
صمدوا لمده اطول فماذا يقول العلم بهذا
الخصوص عوامله مختلفه مشاهدينا تؤثر على
مده بقاء الانسان على قيد الحياه اولها
موقع الانسان عند حدوث الانهيار فالحمايه
الجسديه تحت الحطام قد تساعد على الوصول
الى الهواء ولا شك ان توفر الماء مهم
للغايه للانسان فهو قد يعيش بدون ماء لمده
تتراوح بين ثلاثه وسبعه ايام فقط كما ان
مستوى الاصابات مؤثر للغايه لان فقدان
الدم يقلل من احتمال البقاء على قيد
الحياه اكثر من 24 ساعه ومن العوامل
الهامه التي غالبا ما يتم التقليل من
شانها هي الثبات النفسي والتحكم العقلي
والذي قد يكون امرا حاسما للبقاء على قيد
الحياه